[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the classic sci-fi horror
Event Horizon Callisto protocol in the
Dead Space remake has got me feening for
some survival Horror in space so I
thought I'd revisit the movie that
inspired both games though the film was
a critical and Commercial flop at the
time it's gained a massive following and
I think that's because it's something
that's burden in the brains of every kid
who watched it when they were younger
back in 1997 this was my first real
experience of something that pushed the
limits of body horror this much I think
it had the same effect on a lot of kids
growing up we're all older now and I
think this movie is probably going to
call following due to its scaring us as
kids in a way that left a lifelong
impression director Paul W S Anderson
ended up working with Kurt Russell in
the movie Soldier immediately after this
and naturally he fell down about the
film underperforming whether Russell
said forget about what this movie is
doing now in 15 years time this is gonna
be the movie you're glad you made and
I'm glad he made it too as throughout
this video we're going to be going
through all the creepy details and
things hidden within it that really
Elevate the film and hopefully this
helps you appreciate it even more than
you already do when researching films
like this I try to track down the
origins for them and see what lay the
seeds for the ideas we see on screen
screenwriter fellow bison appeared on
the overheaded movies podcast and he
said that he came up with the idea for
the film when he was watching The
Shining the Stanley Cuba classic is one
of my favorite movies of all time and in
case you haven't seen it it centers
around a family put in charge of looking
after a haunted hotel for the winter due
to poor weather conditions There's No
Escape and Eisner said that he very much
wanted to do a haunted house movie In
Space the Event Horizon was something
you couldn't run out of and leave and
you were trapped in there plagued with
visions of hell and completely at its
Mercy another thing Eisner talked about
was how space is very much hell as well
humans can't survive in it and if you
ever find yourself stuck in space then
you doomed to have an agonizing death as
your lungs implode and the moisture in
your body freezes these were the
building blocks for the movie but it's
also clear that the writer took
inspiration from real life ghost ships
the Mary Celeste is probably the most
famous of these and it was discovered
adrift in the ocean with its crew
completely missing there was no sign of
a struggle and similar to The Event
Horizon it posed an eerie question for
centuries over what really happened on
it now we start off with the Paramount
logo before transitioning into space
absolutely love the way the movie does
this and it takes something common
peaceful looking and instantly gives a
feeling of danger
[Music]
foreign
hopes that we get a directors cut of the
movie with extra footage but
unfortunately when they went to salvage
this they found Powerman hadn't been
looking after it we'll talk about what
was in those deleted scenes later on but
for better or worse this is the only cut
we'll ever get now from here we get what
appears to be a black hole that then
transforms into an eye as we go further
into this lines begin to appear and it
starts to transform into a tunnel
leading towards the dark Center this is
very important iconography and it
similar repeats throughout the entire
film the gravity drive on the Event
Horizon is a black hole that too appears
like an eye a rounded a rings and in
order to get there one has to travel
through a bridge which sort of acts like
a tunnel when crafting the design of the
ship the creative team took a lot of
inspiration from the cathedral in Notre
Dame and it was built to have this
Gothic look to it Conjuring up demonic
imagery in order to get to the drive
itself the passengers also have to
travel through a smaller tunnel lined
with razor sharp spinning Rings this was
done to resemble the Nine Circles of
Hell from Dan Inferno and in order to
get to the center one has to pass
through this now that work contains
black holes which inspired the film and
it also has Latin inscriptions above
gateways which say a ban and hope all ye
who enter later on they receive a
horrifying message in Latin and this
ends up saying
now this is thought to translate to save
me however it's misheard with its use
here actually meaning save yourself now
as we mentioned earlier the drive being
like an eye is also very important it
gives the impression that something is
constantly watching in a very much
reflects the saying that when one stares
into the abyss the abyss stares back
this is very much a black hole at the
center of a ship that has the ability to
also create black holes eyes are so many
that are constantly brought up
throughout the film and at the end Dr
Weir says where we're going we won't
need eyes to see now an event horizon
scientific terms is something that's
Central to a black hole and it's linked
to the escape Velocity that you'd need
to escape one black holes have a gravity
pull that means it's almost impossible
to leave and light itself can't even get
out of one this is why black holes look
black as they're completely absent of
light and as we need light to see the
characters wouldn't need eyes when they
go into one now from here we get a
rundown of man's achievement since 1997.
what's that say 2015 burst permanent
Colony on the moon
alright Marty McFly 2032 apparently had
mining on Mars and in 2040 The Event
Horizon was launched now obviously for
some reason in the 80s and 90s we had a
much more optimistic view of what
Humanity would be able to achieve in the
next 40 years back in the future was of
course one and don't even get me started
on Blade Runner thinking what 2019 would
be like obviously the creators thought
things would go better than they did and
this is actually reflected in the
uniforms at the crew air as well when
creating them Samuel actually requested
that the Union Jack and his Australian
flag should be replaced by an Aboriginal
one to show that they gain independence
from the British but we'll never let you
have it and the US flag also has 55
stars in it and the one for the EU has
22. obviously it's not 2047 yet but hey
fingers crossed we can all come together
anyway we then get some texts that
discusses The Event Horizon itself known
as the worst space disaster on record
the ship was created to explore the
boundaries of our solar system it
disappeared Without a Trace by Neptune
and we discover that it's being cited
once more above the planet having
returned from where it came from the
public would tell the lie and the
official story said that the reactor
went critical which is when it's
self-destructed this was to cover up the
fact that they were attempting to create
faster than life travel which would
break the laws of Relativity and also
the laws of physics in the movie we
discovered that the wormhola drive
opened actually created a gateway to
Hell itself and doors like this have
appeared throughout myths and legends
concocted during medieval times it was
believed that doorways to Hell could be
opened up and that Satan and The Souls
of the dam would transport them to Hell
Ouija boards are thought to be able to
lower the barrier and even in films like
Rosemary's Baby we get the notion that a
Gateway can be created medieval imagery
is laced throughout the movie and though
we can't show it because of YouTube's
stricter monetization policies a lot of
the torture devices are based on those
created in the Middle Ages Notre Dame
itself was completed in the 1300s and we
of course hear Latin throughout the film
when the passengers returned from hell
this was all done to tie our own Dark
Ages and futuristic space travel and I
love the way they've melded the past in
future the idea of Isis ham at home when
we first catch the ship and behind it we
can see the eye of Neptune which acts
almost like it's watching it as
mentioned earlier Event Horizon would go
on to inspire games like Dead Space and
watching it drift past the camera gave
me a lot of feelings of the ishimura we
then cut at the ship itself and can once
more see the large rings outline the
walkway and also pass a watch which is
the Amiga Speedmaster now this is
actually the wristwatch that was worn on
the first American spacewalk which I
think is a nice cool little Easter egg
now from here we catch Dr we are
floating and this is done in front of a
cross symbol to evolve crucifixion
imagery it turns out that this is a
dream that he's having and this actually
plays in the ending of the film though
some people managed to survive Stark has
a vision where she thinks the rescue
crew is headed up by none other than Dr
Weir this being put in place to murder
the opening lends to the possibility
that they might not have escaped the
ship at all and it may be pulling them
back just like how it did with Dr Weir I
don't think that's okay Facebook I
thought I'd bring it up just in case and
we will discuss it more as we hit the
end of the video now we as a tortured
character and we learned that he's
haunted by the guilty feels over his
wife taking her life Guild is something
that's prevalent throughout the film and
the three characters that are hum by the
ship directly all suffer from this on
top of where Peters is the character
that ends up taken by the ship and she
carries the guilt of her broken marriage
and also the fact she left her son on
Earth we discover that Miller tried to
have her a place so that she could stay
and look after a sick son but
unfortunately the transfer didn't go
through in time the death could be
something that he later feels
responsible for and it's clear that she
feels like she abandoned her real child
she's tormented with visions of him and
this Specter very much represents the
guilt that she's carrying alasia's
Captain Miller played by none other than
Lauren's Fishburne we discover that he
abandoned a past crew member and that
they ended up burning to death in space
which was completely agonizing he still
feels guilt over this and his sacrifice
at the end is him very much eternaling
for that loss by staying behind like his
shipmate now it's possible that stock
may carry guilt over this and feel like
she abandoned him which is why she gets
the vision it's important to bear in
mind that each person killed by the ship
had something to atone for and this may
be why we see we're at the end anyway
we're walks about his room and we see a
shrine of photos dedicated to his wife
weirdly there's two of the same ones
here and that's what you get for having
photos mate didn't they have iPhones in
2047 didn't didn't predict that did you
open and crawl your
now he looks at a bathtub which we
discover she drowned in and later on
he'll be basting water surrounded by the
opposite to end fire this very much
represents the fire of hell and water
and fire are of course opposites we are
then opens his blinds now we hear this
sound
foreign
from the video game Doom which is of
course also closely linked to hell now
from here we get an incredible one take
shot of daylight station initially we
start off with an upside down view of
where before we pull out and get a
rotating shot the entire station before
we see it in all its Glory above Earth
[Music]
foreign
now what you probably don't know is that
this 45 second shot actually cost a
third of the film's budget anyway he
reports to the Lewis and Clark which is
where we meet the rest of the characters
it should also does something similar to
the prior one but instead we zoom in on
the ship bfx artist tsuro said it was
the most difficult shot she'd ever
worked on and it involved lining up
different model shots and passes with
footage using real actors now the name
Lewis and Clark was chosen for a
specific reason and it's meant to murder
The Event Horizon Lewis and Clark
carried out an expedition across America
and they mapped out most of the West
during the 1800s The Event Horizon is of
course setting off on its own expedition
in tune territory and it's sort of like
poetry day Rhyme now this is very much a
search and rescue mission and you can
actually see the red U.S Coast Guard
racing stripe painted on the hull the
crew also have a shield on their lapels
which too is a symbol at the Coast Guard
use as mentioned earlier The Event
Horizon is based on ghost ship so this
Coast Guard inclusion is really smart
alongside Justin we also meet Smith
played by Sean Pertwee carrying on the
religious imagery he also draws a sign
of a cross on his chest before the crew
get up and leave now at this point we
get some subtle coffin imagery as Miller
walks through one of the doorways you
may notice that the opening is shaped
like a coffin and this is something that
repeats throughout the film at several
points this has been in animation tubes
it also gave the idea of death with this
catching Koopa floating in one which I
don't know just looks very strange now
you can also catch an AG tattoo on
Smith's back which is supposed to
represent life we then seize the moon
passes in front of Neptune again
creating the cymetry before we cut to
Weir Weir ends up having a nightmare
that he wakes up on the ship and finds
his wife with her eyes missing now
before he spins the chair around we
actually get a reflection of her face in
a screen and if you look along the top
you can catch a pair of eyes almost poop
my pants when I first noticed these and
it gives the feeling that you're
constantly being watched now his wife
very much inspired Nicole in Dead Space
and just in the same way that she
appeared envisions his wife or to it is
too dead space even somewhat took the
ending of this movie with us getting a
jump scare from Nicole whereas yeah it
is of course weird from here we could do
a video of Denny's birthday party and
look at that clown mate may try telling
me this isn't a horror movie now they
sit they sit around the table chatting
away and this is clearly ripping on the
dinner scene that happens in Alien we
can see that Smith also wears a crucifix
and we meet Cooper and DJ in it is is
that is that Lucia's mouth for you
anyway we are explains how wormholds
work and he does this by using a piece
of paper this is something that's been
used in several other films including
Interstellar and more recently in Thor
love and thunder now we discovered that
they were attempting to reach Proxima
Centauri which in reality is one of the
closest stars to our sun this has its
own system of planets that could
potentially one day allow us to inhabit
it again signing into this idea of it
all being an expedition now they
discover the ship after a little bit of
trouble and we see the little toy bear
fall off one of the computers I'm
reaching I'm reaching out I'm reaching
but Justin goes by the nickname baby
bear and Peters goes by the nickname
Mama Bear and they're both full so
foreshadowing anyway they look at this
year through a periscope and this
contains text from the compod mental
destruction of radio tracers as well as
the IBM 1794 they come across to Docking
Bay and we can see Roman numerals on it
these give the number 13 which is of
course thought to be unlucky and the
team suit up and head out and if you
checked out our breakdown of arrival and
you you'll know we talked about how the
hazmat suits on the ship were CGI this
was to help the actors act like they
were in space but in 1997 they didn't
have that kind of Technology everything
had to be done practically and the suits
were extremely heavy this got to the
point that in between takes the crew had
to be suspended on poles to take the
weight off their back 80skids.com
shattered that when Eisner visit they
said Lauren's fish bin shouted your
Eisner you did this to me and the writer
quickly left now you also see the suits
clamped down with Magnetic boots and
again this heavily inspired Isaac Clarke
suit in Dead Space Justin makes his way
into the core and I don't know if I'd be
walking into a room with spikes on the
doors like that but moving on now Peter
discovers the corpse with its eyes out
and cuts across his face and this is
something that we'll later ends up doing
showing how the ship needs a member of
the crew that it can use to carry out
its will the gravity Drive activates and
it pulls Justin while sending out a
Shockwave this causes the Lewis and
Clark to overload unless the crew have
to go into the Event Horizon slowly they
piece together what happened on it and
we see we are explaining how the gravity
Drive Works he stares at it and focuses
on the circles with him seeming almost
like eyes that are then reflected in his
own Peters then discovers the final log
which plays out what happened when they
open the gravity drive this Unleashed
hell and the footage we get here you
know what I'm gonna say can't show it on
YouTube don't read it though and if you
click the more comments on the pin one
I'll leave you a link where you can go
see the images and then come back if not
I was thinking about recreating it but
but we'll try and keep things PJ 13.
everything's on screen for a split
second and it's a montage of mess at
moments that have some of the sickest
body horror I've ever seen there's also
the captain who holds up a pair of eyes
in his hands tying into the fact that
they don't need them to see in hell we
are then crawls into the maintenance
tunnels and we get a similar scene to
alien these cram conditions create
claustrophobia and eventually he's
grabbed by a vision of his wife Miller
sees the crew member he left behind and
this ends up foreshadowing why weird
takes on this form at the end of the
movie Stark concurs that the ship is
indeed alive now and Eisner said he took
inspiration from The Haunting by making
the location just as in Irving as the
events we see playing at after lying
comment hers with his eyes open Justin
then gets up and he goes out to the
airlock the scene is so tense as you
have a countdown going on knowing that
he's about to be thrown into space you
also have a locked room that Stark's
trying to get open and Miller Racing
towards him in order to save his life
each one of these is against the clock
with them desperate to stop what we know
is about to happen Miller manages to
save him but it's clear that the guy has
gone through hell
after hearing the voice of his Doom crew
member Miller sits down with DJ and he
tells him about what happened I love
this shot of the two corridors with them
and it almost creates a feeling of a
face the way the corridor wraps around
them makes it seem like eyes silently
watching them in the background as the
story plays out another says that fire
in space washes over someone like water
and this further is the two elements
together like what we talked about
earlier on the outer hulls Smith and
Cooper fix up the ship which is when
we're begs them to stay he disappears
into the Shadows after saying the ship
won't let them leave which is of course
when it all goes down in a similar scene
to alien we watch two crew members
taking supplies and trying to play the
ship however it Powers up and it trick
speed us into returning after she sees a
vision of her son we get the gravity
Drive reflected in her eyes and as she
runs through the tunnels we can also see
this looks like an eye itself the light
in the background acts as a pupil and
the tunnel itself ends up being the iris
as she climbs a bladder and as she goes
a bit we see doorway shaped like coffins
all around her her son also stands in a
coffin-shaped doorway and this leads to
her falling to her death this idea of
Guild is also murdered and Weir who has
evasion of his wife's death before she
pushes his eyes out this allows him to
see the truth and he starts to kill you
the crew members on board the Lewis and
Clark he places one of the explosives
and Smith discovers this just before it
detonates now Smith could have actually
stopped this as he had six seconds left
and we see a big disarm button big
disarm button right there mate just need
to press that I love how Cooper actually
survives this and with his booty stays
attached to the hull and then blasts
himself back to the ship by purging out
his air tank again Dead Space 2 did
something similar to this when you
finish realigning the solar panels and
had to get yourself back to Titan
station as quickly as he could now DJs
could open and left with his guts
hanging out and the creative team said
that this was a reference to the Silence
of the Lamb's novel which was later
brought into Hannibal Mela finds Stark
on the bridge and we can see that we at
now sits in the captain's chair he ends
up activating the gravity drive and this
then gives them 10 minutes to get off
the ship Cooper makes it back and he
distracts wear so that Miller can escape
and after the window is blown out he
watches everything gets sucked in his
space again Dead Space too they they had
rooms like this and it's such a cool
effect watching everything get pulled
out Weir is taken out too and it very
much rips on the dream that he had at
the start of the movie Cooper takes it
back on board the ship and they then
plan to blow it Miller says look tdrs
will pick up our emergency speaker our
tdrs stands for tracking and data relay
satellite which would be the first thing
that would make contact with them the
ship walls and start to bleed with blood
running along the lights and filling up
the main chamber this comes crashing out
and this is clearly reference to the
elevator scene in The Shining Miller is
knocked in the gravity drive by what
appears to be his friend but as we've
discussed before this is really weird he
detonates the explosives by trapping
himself in with Weir and this ending is
something that's always stuck with me
the guy is just down himself to suffer
in Hell For Eternity and he gets sucked
into the planet after we're constantly
says do you see do you see this is
possibly also reference to Red Dragon
which ties in with the Silence of the
Lamb book before the Lipo manages to
make it out and he watches the event
Horizons pulled into the planet to a
fate and known we close out with a crew
being rescued but with this part of the
ship still remaining we don't know if
the nightmare is truly over it depends
if you see the ship as being alive or
not and whether it's linked to the
gravity drive or the Lifeboat is
detached we are promised that the crew
were all coming with him and this Vision
could be a final scare or it may Hind to
something sinister going on I'll leave
that up to you to decide and as for the
deleted scenes these will come from a
film because test audiences didn't like
them and it completely spooked Paramount
as we mentioned they didn't take care of
them and unfortunately the film has been
lost to time the goal was turned up to
11 with a compilation being extended to
show a woman with her mouth being held
open by clamps and a man drilling into
her teeth the power button screamed for
a split second again we can't show it
but there are bits where stocks being
crucified on a metal bench with barbed
wire wrapped around her head almost like
a crown maggots across people's chest
and let's just say a bit of romance
going on brief glimpses of these moments
specifically are shown in the film but
in the deleted scenes they got much more
Focus now he also heading on to The
Exorcist in which Reagan walked
backwards down the stairs like a spider
instead of Reagan though where would do
this completely nude after The Shining
blood scene the crew would then discuss
their fears with DJ explaining that the
scars on his body were from childhood
operations Peters would also see her
son's legs covered in maggots and me all
in all the horror scenes were slightly
more intense anyway that wraps up the
movie and also our breakdown I had a
blast going through this I hope you saw
something that you hadn't noticed before
if you enjoyed it please drop a thumbs
up and make sure you subscribe for
videos like this every day if you want
to watch your breakdown of arrival that
will be linked on screen right now and
hopefully been enjoying these trips
through older movies the next film I
want to tackle is The Shining so keep an
eye out for that by the way thanks for
clicking the video hope you enjoy the
rest of your week I've been poor you've
been the best don't have nightmares take
care peace